a major new franchise could be coming to
the MCU very soon one that is very
exciting and one that you may not have
guessed would be entering the MCU this
soon how's it going everybody it's
Warren and as if the future of the MCU
wasn't exciting enough with phase four
and phase five coming up with their new
characters and new stories things could
get even more exciting with a new
franchise that could bring completely
new and different characters into the
MCU characters that fans have been
waiting an extremely long time to see in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe quick
reminder I'm still giving away an xbox
one or a ps4 all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain we know a
lot about phase 4 we know all of the
movies that are going to be coming out
within the next couple of years and we
know all of the shows as well but if you
noticed phase 4 is pretty short it's
only two years long and Kevin Feige has
named dropped a lot of other franchises
that are not in phase 4 that could be
coming in phase 5 after all Kevin Feige
has said in multiple interviews that
they have all of phase 5 done and
they've even thought about revealing it
but ultimately they decided not to
reveal it however we do still have the
dates that Marvel has booked for
releases and for one of these dates it
said that a big new franchise is going
to be coming this report originally
comes from Charles Murphy of Murphy's
Law podcast his report originally
started with this a lineup of all of the
phase 4 movies and shows plus four extra
spots for phase 5 with 2 movies named
now Charles has been right about scoops
in the past as you can see here he
stated Ant Man 3 on here way before it
was announced and confirmed which it
just was a few days ago as you can see
here it says Black Panther 2 may 6 2012
and then Ant Man 3 July 29th 2022 as
well but he has two dates on there with
no movie titles now the 2024 surprise
emoji face one is widely believed to be
the next crossover event probably not a
huge one like Avengers infinity war or
Avengers in game but something like
Avengers or Avengers age of Ultron but
that February 2022 date is now believed
to be the introduction of a brand-new
major franchise coming to the MCU and
fortunately for us that has been
narrowed down to what this franchise
could be now during one of his podcast
he referred to this February of 2022
date as limbo now in the Marvel Universe
in the comics limbo refers to a two
separate pocket dimension and Marvel
Comics the first dimension mostly known
as the other place was a dimension of
demons ruled by Belasco but it was
mainly featured in the x-men the second
dimension is ruled by immortus who is
the future self of King now this made a
lot of people's head spin but
fortunately for us Charles Murphy gave a
little bit more information about this
future film while everyone was doing
detective work to try and figure out
what this film could be Charles Murphy
took to Twitter and said haven't heard
too much lately from all you detectives
out there so here's an additional tidbit
about limbo it is the first film in what
the studio plans to be a franchise he
went on to say obviously the box office
will determine that but I can tell you
the studio has indicated there will be
more than one film for this IP so here
he confirmed that Marvel Studios not
only plans to release a new movie but
plans on it to be a franchise and
luckily for us Charles kind of told us
what it is he tweeted a list of four
movies and said one of them was the
correct film for the franchise and the
February 2022 spot and the movies that
were included in those four spots were
Captain Britain Deadpool three Fantastic
Four and blade and out of all of these
four movies that he listed we can pretty
much narrow it down to two blade is most
likely not going to be coming out in
2022
it's most likely a lot further away than
that and even though there is a lot of
hype around it and Marvel Studios is
definitely excited about it announcing
it at San Diego Comic Con and bringing
martial Ollie onstage blade wasn't
really on Marvel's radar until Marshall
Ollie gave them a call so it's pretty
doubtful that it could come in 2022
especially that early in February of
2022 and then we have Captain Britain
now Captain Britain may seem a little
far-fetched and a little out there but
let's not forget about the major Captain
Britain Easter egg that was dropped in
Avengers endgame in Avengers in game
Tony Stark and Captain America travel
back in time and go back to camp Lehi
which was the birthplace of Captain
America himself while trying to go
undetected Steve jumps into a random
office that happens to be the Office of
the love of his life Peggy Carter while
he's in the office he notices her
talking to another SHIELD agent and
during this conversation she mentioned
something about an agent named Brad out
who hasn't checked in yet
now if you're only a MCU fan this name
means nothing but if you're a comic book
fan you know the name Brian Braddock
Brian Braddock is Captain Britain and in
the comics he gets his powers from the
legendary magician Merlin after he's in
a car accident so perhaps the reason
Braddock isn't checking in is because
he's been in an accident and perhaps
this is where he gets his powers in the
MCU Kevin Feige has dropped Captain
Britain before but really hasn't gone
into any detail at all about him however
spider-man far from home did tease us
with the multiverse and although it
wasn't truly introduced in spider-man
far from home you can probably guess
that it's going to be coming to the MCU
any time now after all Avengers end game
left a lot of gaps for alternate
universes one of which apparently Loki
is going to be running around in his new
series coming to Disney Plus so the
multiverse is probably coming soon and
Captain Britain is in charge of
protecting the multiverse so there's a
connection there and not to mention his
sister Betsy Braddock better known as
the mutant Psylocke obviously has a
connection to the mutants which are
going to be coming to the MCU as well
however nothing has really been spoken
about Captain Britain in some time now
and given the fact that when Tony and
Steve went back in time they went back
in time to 1970 so the braddock they're
mentioning most likely isn't Brian
Braddock but is most likely his father
so it's probably a safe bet to take
Captain Britain off of this list so now
we're left with two Deadpool three and
the Fantastic Four both of which make
perfect sense now Deadpool 3 is very
likely especially because we know that
Ryan Reynolds has recently met with
Marvel Studios not to mention he has
teased Deadpool coming to the MCU
several times on Instagram now Deadpool
is most likely going to be a reboot
obviously they're going to keep Ryan
Reynolds but unfortunately most of the
other cast will probably go away however
we definitely know that the film is
going to break down the fourth wall and
Ryan Reynolds will most likely make a
ton of jokes about Deadpool going from
the Fox universe into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and this is going to
be an entirely different franchise than
the Fox one and there's also the
possibility that the franchise may not
even be
to the MCU but Deadpool could still
appear in MCU films and the reason for
this would be so Deadpool could remain
rated R but the MCU could remain being
rated pg-13
so Deadpool might exist outside of the
MCU in his solo films that would be
rated R obviously him breaking down the
fourth wall talking about it as well as
a joke kind of existing in the MCU but
kind of existing out of it but then
existing in the MCU when he does team
ups like with the Avengers or with
somebody that we've all been waiting for
spider-man and not to mention Deadpool
is sort of in limbo right now or at
least he was when Disney bought Fox that
was sort of unclear what was going to
happen to Deadpool and for a while he
was just kind of floating around there
like he was in limbo so perhaps this is
the film the new franchise to Disney at
least that Charles Murphy is talking
about that is going to be coming in 2022
however there is a possibility that it
could be the Fantastic Four when the
Disney Fox deal was complete and Kevin
Feige was asked about when the Fantastic
Four and the x-men are going to be
entering the MCU implied that the
Fantastic Four would be coming a lot
sooner than the x-men and that makes
perfect sense because the Fantastic Four
are just four new characters plus a
villain the x-men are a whole group of
characters with a whole lot of the ones
as well and then at San Diego comic-con
Kevin Feige name-drop the Fantastic Four
an teen named draft the mutants now
there have been previous reports that
the Fantastic Four could be coming in
2022 now these were before Charles
Murphy's report but something new has
recently come up ant-man 3 has recently
been confirmed and ant-man 2 or Ant Man
and the wasp had a really really big
secret the quantum city that was
discovered that everybody thought was
going to be a really big part of
avengers endgame now obviously this was
not in the movie but Marvel teased us
with talking about how important it was
clearly this is going to be something
brought up in ant-man 3 and right now
it's assumed that this is how the
Fantastic Four are going to be
introduced into the MCU it's possible
that the Fantastic Four being scientists
went into the quantum realm somewhere
during the 1960s when they went into the
quantum realm they could have somehow
gotten stuck in the negative zone this
could
also beware they could have gotten their
superpowers we already know that Janet
Van Dyne said an ant-man and the wasp
that the quantum realm changes you and
she came out with some type of healing
powers so it's clear that the quantum
realm does kind of enhance you and give
you abilities and since the Fantastic
Four are so connected to the quantum
realm or the Microverse as it's called
in the comics it would make sense that
they are already stuck in the quantum
realm because the premise has already
been set in ant-man and the wasp with
the quantum city and it would also make
sense that they would get their powers
from the quantum realm just like Janet
Van Dyne did however Charles Murphy has
Ant Man 3 listed for the July of 2022
spot that's after the February 2022 spot
which is where Charles says a new
franchises coming in so unless he's off
about the ant-man 3 date the Fantastic
Four most likely will not be that spot
unless the quantum city and the quantum
realm have nothing to do with the
Fantastic Four at all and they won't
appear in ant-man 3 which doesn't seem
very likely so as it stands right now
it's looking like Deadpool 3 is going to
be taking that February 2022 spot unless
Marvel plans on doing a solo Fantastic
Four movie before introducing them or
teasing them in a post-credits scene in
any other MCU film which could be likely
as well but let me know what you think
about this which of these four choices
would you like to see into the MCU as a
brand new franchise would you like blade
Captain Britain Deadpool or the
Fantastic Four to appear in 2022 in the
MCU let me know down below also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to my channel if you'd like a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 winner gets to
choose the winner will be picked when I
hit five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof